[Music]
an avalanche of new footage has released
via tv spot to new trailers from the
film so let's just get straight into it
and break down this new footage so peter
makes a hero land in his doc oct greets
him with hello peter peter then says do
i know you and then we get a new voice
line from doc ox saying do you think
your fancy new suit will save you we
then cut to a very cool new shot of what
looks like peter breaking out of a car
or a bus using his iron spider now gotta
say i really like the animation of the
iron spider here it looks very
spider-like and i don't know it seems
just very cool and different to what
we've usually seen with this iron spider
we then have another new line from doc
ock which he says looks like we got
competition now what i'm wondering is is
this referring to peter and his iron
spider or is this referring to green
goblin because we know sometimes during
this sequence that green goblin swoops
into scene and joins the fight so what
i'm wondering is when he says it looks
like we've got competition is he
referring to green goblin let me know
what you guys think but let's continue
to end off the new footage of doctor
octopus here we have him slamming peter
underneath the bridge to then saying
you're not peter to which spider-man
responds with i am so confused right now
we have new footage for my lecture which
you can see playing in the background
here nothing too much to break down here
but i gotta say i'm really loving his
new design anyway moving on to the next
part of the footage we have footage from
sandman now we actually haven't had too
much footage from sandman in this film
so far so it's good to get more footage
and what we have here in the first shot
is him reaching out which is quite
reminiscent of him from spider-man 3.
and then over to the next set of the
footage we have him actually grabbing
and crushing peter here which looks like
this is also from the construction
battle which we saw at the end of the
official trailer now i think this battle
will probably take part towards the end
of the film yeah peter this is happy who
are those guys huh one of the guys made
a mud what's going on call me back so we
actually have some new footage from
happy here and to be honest he doesn't
seem too happy he seems quite confused
and worried about these new guys these
new villains which he doesn't know who
they are so he's trying to call peter
here and ask about who these new guys
are do you know anything about it why
are they here can you stop them i was
reading online that people were thinking
happy is referring to the other
spider-man here being like oh who are
these guys you know anything about that
however there's a line where he says it
looks like there's some guy made of mud
obviously that is referring to sandman
which means she is referring to the
villains and not the other spider-man
now i was talking about sam and how we
haven't had too much new footage from
him well also that is the same case for
the lizard we have basically had no new
footage of him apart from a couple
second clip where he's at the bottom of
the screen in a fight sequence we
finally got some new footage of the
lizard it's very short but it's just him
roaring which is pretty cool
was that a dinosaur to say the design
looks great and you can also notice he
actually has four fingers on his right
hand compared to five on his left in the
next set of footage peter is saying um
he needs some help and then ned comes in
and says let's catch some multiverse man
now one thing to note here is that um
doctor strange was doing a spell so they
everyone can forget that it was peter
parker yet ned knows his spider-man so
i'm wondering did peter tell them again
or because the spell failed does that
mean everyone still knows he is
spider-man so in the sequence where
peter parker has grabbed the cube and is
on the run from doctor strange we have
some new footage here basically he's on
the train however this time around there
are cities everywhere so some crazy
doctor strange stuff going on there
anyway that's pretty much it for the new
footage that we've got from tv spots and
trailers i'm sure there'll be many new
tv spots coming in the coming days up to
the film's release so if you want more
videos covering the footage like this
one please let me know in the comment
section below and also let me know what
do you think of this new footage are you
guys excited for the new film let me
know and also to show your support
please like subscribe and turn
notifications on thanks for watching
guys